selon le ministre russe de la Défense le
maire de la capitale assure que les
dégâts sont mineurs et qu'il n'y a pas
de victimes la Russie accuse directement
Kiev Noémie roche
c'était ce matin à l'aube la capitale
russe frappée par une attaque de drone
ce matin le régime de Kiev a mené une
attaque terroriste avec des drones
contre des sites à Moscou 8 drones ont
été impliqués dans la taxe ils ont tous
été neutralisés
une offensive rare située à plus de 1000
km de l'Ukraine Moscou et sa région ont
jusqu'ici été relativement épargnés par
ce type d'attaque même si celle-ci se
sont multipliées ailleurs en Russie une
attaque qui fait suite à une offensive
intense et en plusieurs vagues sur la
capitale ukrainienne au petit matin ses
habitants de Kiev avaient encore du mal
à réaliser ce à quoi ils ont échappé
tout le monde ici a survécu on est
heureux d'être en vie mais on pense à ce
qui va arriver ensuite
la maison tremblait de toutes parts
c'était terrifiant on doit vraiment
rester dans les abris parce qu'on ne
sait jamais où les drones vont tomber
une ambiance de terreur qui règne dans
la capitale depuis lundi c'est la
troisième attaque aérienne vison Kiev en
l'espace de 24 heures les autorités
ukrainiennes affirment avoir détruit 29
drones sur 31